he is a New York Times bestselling
author who's also the founder president
and CEO of FUBU founder of the shark
group and also one of the Sharks on
Shark Tank season 10 premiere Sunday
October 7th at 10:00 p.m. Eastern on ABC
good to see you Daymond John Thank You
van bet like I said to the TV audience
you were in their New York digs welcome
to our Los Angeles digs cooling a lot of
leather
thank you yeah where leather is with us
here in the Rich Eisen show studio here
in Los Angeles
first things first Shark Tank returns on
on on Sunday October 7th how is it doing
the [ __ ] how many years have you done
you are you an original shyam an
original shark I was the first shark to
uh you know put my feet on the stage
spent 10 years you know we got people
coming on there saying I was a kid and I
grew up one shark tank I mean that
doesn't make me feel great in some
senses but it makes me feel amazing
another right I know that they're
staying power but then again there's
there's been substantial when somebody
says that to you today I was in grade
school when I first started watching you
and and how has it changed how does it
change do you think at all I think it's
changing various ways you know you
really think about it only came out in
oh eight you know social media
conversion was not out there you know I
don't even think Instagram was thought I
know that um Facebook may have been
maybe Instagram was out you know the the
the the people pitching know the Sharks
we have no idea who they are so they're
coming in there with an idea who they
want to work with they know how to push
our buttons you know they can you know
it's just exchanged so many different
ways we have a lot of other guest sharks
now who bring another you know way of
thinking and the fundamentals of
business we can object or agree but
however you know there's new sharks in
you know after I sit there 10 years and
listen to Kevin O'Leary with a couple
royalty deals he's my getting numb to it
right but the Bethenny comes in there
who was a very successful businesswoman
and she has a different way of thinking
about something or you know you know we
can either lock horns or totally agree
on a rod a rod a rod been really great
yeah I have miss a turn a panel with him
meaning in the tank seven other panels
so you know
but they're really it's really amazing I
mean the show is oh we have this year
ring the guy from ring Jaime he came
into the tank I think six years ago or
five years ago he had an idea we all
shot him down he would go off and sell
his company for 1.1 billion dollars and
now he's a shark so he was in the tank
as a hedging pitching got rejected I
rejected I mean Kevin gave him a royalty
deal he he would say today and he has
said it several times that you know what
my valuation was crazy I didn't know
what I was doing at the time but he
would go off and he would build his
company sell for 1 point 1 billion
dollars to Amazon that sort of B naught
million and now he is a guest shark now
he's a shark that must have been a good
day for him that's a good day for
everybody cuz you know what this shows
that you know the Sharks you know nobody
can judge you but God and we can only
say to you if the investment works for
us yes go out and prove us wrong we
don't know everything
so which one Daymond John here on the
Rich Eisen show which one that you said
yes to that you helped and fostered are
you most proud of over your 10 years I'm
not gonna say most proud of but one of
my top ones is a company called bomba
Sox every time you buy a stock they give
a pair away to the homeless because
that's a big challenge and the homeless
shelters to care for people's feet and
you know they started off in the tank
doing about $800,000 a year now they're
doing an average of I think 50 or 60
million a year and they've given away 10
million socks to people in need it's not
only given me a great return on my
capital but it's also showed me that you
know today's consumer they want to know
what are you doing for other people if
you're gonna purchase something you know
if they're gonna purchase something from
you and then let's let's turn to a
business deal that it seems to have gone
down in in the world of shoes sneakers
apparel yeah that involves social
activism I'd love to know what your
thoughts are on Nike choosing Colin
Kaepernick to be the face of their 30th
anniversary just do it campaign you know
I was very very excited when it happened
I've told many people you know about it
publicly and you know now we can talk
about how it has positively affected
you know their stock numbers but end of
the day I'm I love what they did you
know because this is the first time you
ever saw a major corporation jump on the
side of somebody who's having these
social issues at the time they were
having it as a major company they could
await it you know if it was 40 years ago
when this was Muhammad Ali Billie Jean
King or Arthur Ashe everybody would have
waited for a while and said let's see
how the dust settles and and we don't
want to take our tunity you know take
advantage of this right now and or bring
light to it but they did it right away
in the moment and the stock numbers have
shown you know what it is but listen
let's think about the reality of this
you know the people who may have
protests sort of feel you know uneasy
about what they believe you know
Kaepernick is trying to do which they
may be inaccurate talking about our our
our great men and women in the service
you know they may be a little older
right now and Nikes selling to kids who
are 10 to 25 years old and you know I
don't care if you're 50 years old if
you're going out buying three new three
brand-new pair of sneakers at $180 a
piece you're an idiot
all right but the people they're selling
to are rebelling within the system and
they're communicating ten times more
than the people who are a little more
older or mature my each I'm not buying
10 pair of sneakers well so what do you
attribute this decision-making to do you
think that they they followed their
social activist heart or they actually
did some number crunching before they
did something they're big corporation
they did some number crunching at first
and I think then they brought it to the
board and everybody else and they
probably said I mean let's look at Nike
they're doing 35 billion dollars a year
15 billion dollars of that money is you
know international money they couldn't
care less who kneels and or stands for a
flag so now they had the twenty billion
dollars of their core customer in the
United States they probably lost about
three billion dollars in those people
who said okay you know this is not
something for us we disagree but they
probably gained instead of that and
replace it with another five to eight
billion dollars worth of consumers you
know fighting within the system so I
think that number one it was a good play
that they did by crunching the numbers
but number two they also did you know go
a little bit with let's let's let's go
outside of the green and let's let's
let's ride with this well cuz Daymond
John from shark tank also the president
CEO founder of FUBU founder of the shark
group brand management and consulting
firm here on the Rich Eisen show that
you know copper Nick is suing the NFL
right now yeah and the NFL collusion
right collusion and that case is moving
forward and I I picked up a lot of the
numbers that you just threw out there
the was think any concern of having a
face of their campaign be be somebody
who's suing one would think I don't know
what their numbers are compared to what
college football brings in a college
basketball brings in the face of
somebody who is suing their main partner
in the professional football I do think
that there was a big concern there and I
think that they roll the dice on this
situation but you know it now let's
think about this that the NFL would have
then given them a backlash over that you
know it's a nasty rabbit hole that they
would have went down so you know today
you know what I look at it is my the
current version of FUBU
you know FUBU was for a culture and you
sees a guy or a girl wearing FUBU cross
street you knew they were into hip-hop
today now you see somebody who's walking
on to the Hemis or you know Jim Carrey
walking on and showing me as a Nikes
you're like you know what they're
rebelling within the system you know who
they are without even speaking you know
how they think if they have a brand new
pair of Nikes but it was a big it was a
big you know it was a big risk they took
do you think that this will lend more I
guess courage is a word but or or more
conviction you know of corporate America
to think of making a business deal with
social activism in a way absolutely will
also give more fuel to social activism
meaning the you know other athletes will
believe that if they're you know if they
can do it you know that maybe they'll
have other ways to feed their families
off of you know standing up for what
they believe in
so yeah
it's a big risk but now you know all the
other companies are gonna follow suit
and start saying wow look at these
numbers you know like we need to you
know stand behind something and that's
not easy to stand behind something
because there's always two sides of the
coin right Daymond John here on the Rich
Eisen show and so when it all comes down
to it when you built your business and
see the way that Nike is doing their
business do you think that this might
even lend colin kaepernick to lend his
name to other companies as well do you
think because now he has validation it's
amazing he has how this might be a game
changer and this is a huge huge
game-changer in the world of business
yes absolutely
huh how many people come up to you and
pitch you on ideas just off just when
you're sitting around on the street not
including my mother probably about you
know your mom is pitching you mom
pissing me all the time you know
probably about 40 about 30 people a day
come on yeah come on yeah about 30
people so have you been pitched today
has anybody pitched you yet today no no
it's pretty early in the morning okay so
can we can we get you your first pitch
can we do can we give you a first pitch
here absolutely I'm ready Rock I
appreciate you saying that
Mike Dell 2fo who by the way just in
terms of his branding he's got a Nike
swoosh on rise you could say he was it
right on right on and in terms of him
understanding branding he wants to be
known around here as the audio executive
all right you see what I'm saying yeah
what is your technical term what is your
official like what do you engineer
Audioengine like the executive wants to
be known as audio exactly exactly I like
it all right okay now he pitched kevin
O'Leary about a year ago and what did
Kevin say about that pitch
I should be in it I should literally be
crying still fetal position within a
couple of minutes so here we go
Mike tell 2fo we have set up a standing
mic for you to pitch let's go buddy
Daymond John
available again with the rest of the
sharks on Sunday October 7th 10 p.m.
eastern time on ABC
Mike del 2 foe you now have the floor
with Daymond John to pitch him on this
brilliant idea
Daymond I have a great idea the last
idea I didn't like as much even though I
kind of came in with it a little bit
with guns blazing but this one sports
betting is now back gambling is coming
back it's gonna be it's gonna be all
over America so it's gonna be legal in
states it's gonna be legal in cities
it's gonna be gigantic so I thought of
an idea in the last 12 hours actually
what these guys are laughing about why
don't we have sports bars that are set
up with the gambler in mind with iPads
eventually it's going to be legal
everywhere with iPads where they can
place the bets they can bring their kids
because we make it like a Chucky Cheese
meets at Dave & Buster's the kids can
play with the games they want to do you
put up the sports bet Justin you seen
Vegas you got the support spent walls
the monitors you tell them the city's
New York is tailored for the Yankees the
Rangers the Mets the nets the Knicks
Chicago's of bears you know you got it
Bulls LA's got the Clippers you build
rooms where people that want to go and
watch the you know they build it with
like jerseys hanging from those those
teams so the people go there and they
feel like I can watch my team here have
a good time but I can also gamble
and I can come to a place where other
people that are like me are gambling and
then you could have incentives you pick
a team you're picking over/under you get
a free drink if you're right
you pick a halftime score well anything
that happens like that what do you think
yeah so you're you're asking should you
know people who are alcoholics and
gambling degeneres bring their kids with
them too yes I mean when you're trying
to place a bed and watch a game what do
you do with the kids maybe you bring
them in Y and they're in a separate room
it's amazing have you ever been shopping
with your kids I don't have kids but I
have shopped with my nieces and nephews
yeah
so you don't so so the REIT you know the
reason why people don't generally go
shopping on their kids because the kids
you know are pain in the ass they take
them out of the store so you're you know
if you have you ever been to Vegas
oh yeah and you've seen the people of
the slot machines for 19 hours of we're
doing nickel slot machines yes if they
had children with them then they would
be you know they wouldn't be there any
longer so you have a couple of
challenges there number one you wouldn't
get the customer to retain to be there
long enough because the kid's gonna be
annoying them and then if they're
drinking alcohol they start probably
beating the kids so let's say let's say
we go just for the degenerate remove the
child care the child generates in the
room right now what our researcher and
yes Las Vegas but they have to go to
Vegas if you wanted to do it like just
Los Angeles in New York yeah I mean
that's true but yeah is there is there
colonel is there a colonel you know
boozing gambling I mean all you're
missing at that point is prostitution in
the place I mean they're really getting
even stinky in various ways but um I
don't think it's gonna happen but I love
the way you work the audio I mean at
Reilly amazing I tried measured you
should you should you should hear he
referred to himself as the Bill Walsh of
audio because he's got so many great
sound people across Los Angeles that he
has created like a coaching they won't
admit it though that's why I like I like
your style though we're gonna go out and
get some drinks and roll some craps
later on thanks gentlemen that don't
good after Mike see now you were much
nicer than that was nice and Kevin
O'Leary's worse than that that he
pitched Kevin O'Leary was a nap but your
loved ones check in it allows you every
single time your loved ones on the phone
it checks in to make sure that you know
that they're okay well that's the
problem
that's the problem kevin O'Leary doesn't
have any loved ones
[Laughter]
just told Mike to call his mother I need
to call your mother more thanks again
for coming on the show is awesome good
to see you Damon thank you thanks Sammy
with at the shark gameand on twitter if
you want to follow Daymond John on
Twitter and of course follow the
exploits of Shark Tank premiering Sunday
October 7th at 10 p.m. Eastern on ABC
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience